bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire où l'on
discute des sujets qui font l'actualité
un enfant sur deux ne sait pas nager en
français le constat fait en 2019 par
roxana maracineanu la ministre des
sports depuis 2015 un plan est en place
j'apprends à nager c'est pour les
enfants de 6 à 12 ans alors comment
développer l'apprentissage de la
natation on en parle avec nos invités le
sucre est un bon soir bonsoir c'est un
plateau vous êtes maire adjoint aux
sports de montigny-le-bretonneux et
virginie portal bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes la présidente du comité
départemental de la fédération française
de natation et je vais commencer avec
vous puisque des craintes étaient
partagés par les professionnels et le
monde de la natation l'été dernier sur
une possible recrudescence des noyades
en cause la crise sanitaire qui a fait
fermer de nombreux sites de natation
donc des courants - quelle est la
situation aujourd'hui
écoutez je crois que il est quand même
pas mal de soucis au niveau de la
natation ce que comme vous le disiez pas
mal de sites de deux fermes et donc
beaucoup moins de cours donc à vous
soucier par rapport à l'apprentissage de
la natation justement donc il faut tout
remettre en place pour éviter le nombre
de noyades augmente encore plus là
michel crotales centre aquatique du lac
de montigny bretonneux justement il ya
des créneaux en plus qui avait émis en
juin dernier pour pallier ces problèmes
complètement parce qu'on avait on aurait
créé des donc des créneaux sur la
prévention noyade qui permettait à des à
des enfants qui avaient déjà enfin
qu'ils ne savaient pas vraiment qu'il y
avait un petit très légère pratique de
faux qui savait pas nager on peut pas
dire ça de cette manière là mais qui
arrivait au moins sur un mètre ou deux
se débrouiller de l'es2 les initiés
pendant deux heures sur
quel est bons gestes à faire et c'est
pour pouvoir éviter justement cette
noyade avant qu'ils apportent
définitivement à nager virginie portal
est ce qu'il ya eu aussi un phénomène où
les gens on l'a entendu ne sont pas
retournés dry théâtre ils sont pas
retournés dans les salles de sport voire
ne sont pas retournés dans les piscines
des lieux de baignade oui ils ont mis un
peu de temps à revenir effectivement
dans les milieux de baignade donc il a
fallu effectivement mettre en place
pour faire revenir les les enfants pour
leur apprendre à leur apprendre à nager
et effectivement les gens un peu en mis
un peu de temps à revenir effectivement
comme pour les théâtres où vous disiez
quoi comme paul et les cinémas
alors doublé depuis 2000 19 une
opération a été lancée par la fédération
française de natation et sophie kamoun
ancienne nageuse de haut niveau et
membre de l'équipe de france de 1982
1992 ça s'appelle nageurs et citoyens
des champions de natation voit la
rencontre de jeunes pour démocratiser la
pratique il était à poitiers à poissy le
25 octobre dernier un reportage de
céline charles et grégory canal et en
france c'est un enfant sur deux qui
arrivent au collège sans savoir nager
trois cents enfants de moins de 6 ans
sont également victimes de la noyade
chaque année face à ce constat sophie
kamoun ex nageuse olympique s'est engagé
aux côtés de sept nageurs de haut niveau
dans le programme nageurs et citoyen
objectif apprendre aux enfants à nager
et on s'est dit qu'en tant que anciens
sportifs de nos anciens nageurs de haut
niveau et il était de notre 2 voire de
mettre notre pierre un petit peu à
l'édifice sur sur le savoir nager que
c'était une cause évidemment nationale
aujourd'hui vous avez 259 gamins du
département qui vont être initiés à la
natation pour certains
conforté dans ce que ça va faire pour
pour d'autres la cause de ces chiffres
alarmants l'inégalité d'accès à la
pratique être en contact avec les
enfants qui sont souvent dans des
quartiers
défavorisés sont peut dire c'est à dire
qu'ils ont pas accès aux piscines par
manque de moyens de temps les transports
qui se prennent trop de temps nageurs et
citoyens il ya d'un côté la natation
mais aussi toutes ces valeurs de
citoyenneté c'est un enjeu de vie la
natation tout de savoir nager d'abord
pour pour éviter de se noyer cqfd mais
aussi sur les vertus les vertus du sport
démocratiser la natation en s'amusant
c'est la volonté de ses nageurs qui
compte bien rendre cette journée de
partage et de transmission plaisante
pour tout le monde
c'est extrêmement ludique le but c'est
que les enfants se sentent bien sentent
en confiance pour qu' il puisse revenir
derrière
nous ça va en fait on va en dessous en
fermant pas pris aux mecs en échange on
sort du lot et après on recommence c'est
bien de là j'ai comme ça on pourra
prendre des nouvelles choses c'est
vraiment le but faire des petits
ateliers d'être là avec eux soit le plus
vite possible un amusement une partie de
plaisir qui ait aucune contrainte le
programme va se démultiplier dans
d'autres villes menthe et les mureaux
vont participer l'année prochaine et
tout le département devrait être de la
partie après les jo de 2024
vient génie portal les champions le 10 à
plusieurs reprises dans le sujet il faut
rendre la natation ludique oui oui c'est
important parce que
plus on pense à lui dit - il y aura
moins il ya de peur et du coup moins il
ya de risque de de noyade est beaucoup
plus c'est facile aussi d'apprendre et
plus on le voit on va les mettre à l'eau
jeunes plus ils vont avoir de facilité à
prendre un avion après on n'a pas tous
la même aisance dans l'eau mais au moins
ils auront moins peur et il y aura il y
aura un apprentissage qui sera plus plus
facile quand c'est ludique mais celui
dit qu'il est présent à
montigny-le-bretonneux michel creton
vous avez le bassin ludique on a le
bassin ludique d'ailleurs on a des
traîneaux qui sont dédiés justement pour
le pour les d'ailleurs à tous les
niveaux puisque on démarre au niveau je
ne sais pas nager jusqu'à de
l'apprentissage au fur et à mesure du
nombre de mètres qu'un jeune peut faire
dans une piscine et donc on a de cette
manière là on a ainsi créé donc vingt
cinq niveaux avec plusieurs créneaux
dans la semaine pour pouvoir pour
permettre ce pop-up et ça y compris des
créneaux de bébés nageurs bon c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose mais c'est
aussi pour pour disons faire en sorte
que les enfants s'habituent à l'eau
puisque l'on voit aussi que il ya
souvent des enfants qui ont peur de
l'eau c'est une peur de l'eau donc il
faut aussi qu'on arrive à les allées à
les rassurer par rapport par rapport à
ce milieu là et qui lorsqu'ils tombent
dans l'aube qu'ils soient pas qu'ils
soient comment dire des ans par ren
combat puisque en fait
c'est leur peur exactement et qu'il
fasse pas comme on faisait autrefois
ce m'est arrivé aussi quand j'étais
jeune en jeter les enfants dans l'eau et
puis débrouillez vous et enfin c'est pas
du tout le cette manière là ça c'est là
c'est une manière pour effectivement
effrayer plus les jeunes que de les
encourager mais justement devient génie
portable vous en parler des bébés
nageurs on sait que les villes sont très
les créneaux sont très vite pris sa
place ou ne serait ce que par la
relation aussi enfin parents moment dans
la piscine est ce qu'il ya un âge à
conseiller pour commencer à nager
plutôt houleuse ayant plus quand vous le
dit sa ferme et aux parents aux listes
dans l'eau avec l'enfant donc il ya un
lien qui est particulier entre
l'enfant et le parent enfin en plus plus
fait ce qu est ce que j ai tout à
l'heure que le plus tôt on va les mettre
dans l'eau - il y aura cette peur mais
ils seront à l'aise avec l'eau et ils
pourront se débrouiller en k2 en cas de
souci donc je pense que effectivement
voilà plus plus tôt on l'aimé et je
pense qu'il y'a pas d'âge il n'ya pas
d'un giro qui en fait un an c'est plutôt
les mieux ce sera
de d'adaptation au mouvement quand on
apprend à des enfants à nager il ya un
âge auquel ils ont pas encore le sens
voilà à faire le petit chien alors que
bon vers 6 à temps ils sont beaucoup
plus la spree pour voir effectivement
synchroniser des les bras et les jambes
donc ça c'est la partie la plus
difficile quoi messi 7 ans on est donc
déjà dans le primaire on est dans le
parcours scolaire obligatoire est ce
qu'on doit rendre finalement les cours
de natation obligatoire dans un
programme scolaire jusque là depuis le
début on est presque sûr une démarche
personnelle des parents virginie portal
moi je pense qu'il faudrait
effectivement que ce soit obligatoire
qu'on soit obligé de de savoir nager
avant d'arriver au collège ça ça paraît
évident parce qu'il ya plus en plus de
piscines il ya plus voilà on part à la
mer il ya voilà c'est vraiment risqué
pour moi effectivement je pense que le
maître obligatoires ça me parait milan
michalek fnac il y à quelle part de
scolaires vous avez sur le centre
aquatique on a aujourd'hui les donc les
16 écoles élémentaires de la ville font
bon la piscine en battant l'as tout ça
en discussion avec l'éducation nationale
puisque c'est eux qui font les
programmes et donc on a privilégié cette
année tous les ce2 donc c'est des
enfants aux 7 8 ans donc tous les tous
les enfants donc ils vont avoir une
dizaine d'heures je crois 10 ou 12
heures sur deux pratique donc là c'est
largement suffisant pour leur apprendre
à effectivement nager le problème c'est
qu'on peut pas en prendre plus
aujourd'hui pour les raisons sanitaires
que met on en a eues on a eu beaucoup
plus de des caisses de classe on essaie
de vraiment de passer en revue toutes
les classes alors plus cdd des rythmes
différents d'une sur l'année scolaire et
en plus on accueille nous les écoles
aussi deux voisins puisque la la piscine
et et partager avec lui avec moi
vous l'avais dit à différents rythmes
aussi une place et entre 25 et 30 élèves
vient gêner portal j'imagine que dans la
natation aussi plus il ya des lèvres -
on a le temps de nager est-ce qu'il faut
aussi repenser sa est ce que la
fédération française de natation
aimerait discuter de ce côté là aussi
avec avec les ministères de l'éducation
et des sports pour prévoir des cours
comme on peut voir des cours de sport de
deux heures trois heures au collège et
au lycée après mais c'est vrai que quand
on voit les heures de natation c'est
vrai que le temps d'arriver le temps de
se mettre en halo effectivement le
nombre d'enfants que assez nombreux ça
laisse pas énormément temps dans l'eau
pour l'apprentissage c'est vrai que ça
serait peut-être intéressant d'avoir des
créneaux horaires un peu plus important
pour peut-être faire des goûts ou voilà
faire qu'on puisse vraiment avoir un
réel apprentissage
qu'on ne leur demande pas d'apprendre la
nage de manière toutes les nages codifié
en vraiment c'est à ne plus savoir se
débrouiller dans l'eau mais justement
parce qu est ce qu on appelle savoir
nager quand on sait à quel moment peut
dire qu'une personne sait nager c'est
dire une question de distance parcourue
ou de gestes pratiqués parce que savoir
nager c'est savoir se débrouiller quand
on est dans un milieu aquatique où on à
papier
savoir du coup à
accéder au bord du bassin quand on à
papier savoir revenir au bord de la mer
après on leur demande pas que ce soit
une trace parfait tout
mais voilà c'est ça surtout ça c'est
savoir nager c'est à voir les gestes
pour se mettre en sécurité en fait tout
simplement des crétins parmi les
pratiquants qui se déplace dans le
centre aquatique c'est plus du loisir on
vient à géant bien profiter d'un moment
famille alors il ya effectivement il ya
les deux en fait on a on a vraiment une
clientèle de personnes qui viennent pour
nager dont qui occupent les lignes d'eau
donc ils sont qui font des bassins d un
bon ça c'est sûr l appart la pratique
sportive de la natation effectivement
l'autre partie c'est entre les les
différents courts dont je vous parlais
tout à l'heure les différents niveaux
donc on a effectivement là pas mal de
voeux d'occupation de ses credo là et
puis il ya pas mal de familles aussi qui
viennent justement dans les bassins
ludiques dans les toboggans
donc ça c'est aussi la partie vraiment
ludique et attractive de la piscine et
c'est vraiment un mélange de tous et de
tout ce qu'on a et c'est effectivement
le problème quand on évoque aujourd'hui
c'est plutôt la difficulté qu'ont ces
personnes-là à revenir maintenant après
tout ce qu'on a connu et qui fait que
bon ils sont assez méfiant en fait
aujourd'hui rien n'est dit qu'un milieu
aquatique dans lequel il ya déjà
d'énormes précautions sanitaires mises
en mise en oeuvre je n'ai rien pas plus
de risques que dans un autre milieu ou
d'aller au théâtre opportunité à tout à
l'heure mais je pense qu'il ya moins de
risques dans une piscine que dans un
tertre aujourd'hui a priori il ya aussi
des cours d'aqua d'aquaphobie amandinois
tout à fait qu'est ce que c'est alors ça
sort pour les personnes qui ont vraiment
la peur de l'eau et en fait on leur en
ces cours sont destinés à ces personnes
là et on essaie de les désigner deux
sets de cette peur
à travers de différentes méthodes
qui ont été conçus par par des personnes
portées par des médecins justement pour
enlever cette phobie de l'eau
virginie portal 1 suisse a conçu un
camion piscine qui sillonnent les routes
pour aller à la rencontre ça se passe
dans le nord de la france actuellement
est-ce que c'est aussi un bon moyen de
démocratiser la nage oui c'est un bon
moyen parce que ça permet d'amener
l'eau on va dire un espace aquatique
dans des endroits où on n'a peut-être
pas la possibilité finalement de ne
pouvoir y aller facilement ou n'a
peut-être pas forcément les moyens aussi
de ya les certains pas tous les moyens
aussi d'aller d'année d'aller nager
d'apprendre à nager donc je pense que ça
c'est un bon moyen ou est d'amener
d'amener la piscine à des endroits où
effectivement mon nom et il y en a pas
on en a pas assez en fait donc ses liens
ces bonnes idées moi je trouve ces
crétins oui les moyens c'est quelque
chose aussi qui peut bloquer ah bah oui
complètement ça je pense que aujourd'hui
on regarde 150,1 par exemple il ya
aujourd'hui de mémoire trois piscines en
activité une quatrième qui arrive avec
la mort pas bon pour 220 mille habitants
donc c'est pour moi c'est insuffisant
effectivement ce que tu partes et moi il
ya une trentaine de piscines et de lieux
de baignade est donc aujourd'hui
effectivement le problème je crois que
le problème il et puis plus nationale
sur effectivement la
l'obtention de de ce type de fansites et
d'équipements qui aujourd'hui on le sait
est très cher et est assez peu rentable
mais l'idée c'est pas votre d'être
rentable surtout de pouvoir idée que me
disait malade tout à l'heure d'avoir de
permettre à des jeunes de pouvoir de
pouvoir nager d'apprendre à nager et de
pas arriver comme je vais discuter
l'autre jour avec le proviseur de lycée
ou s'aperçoit que un quart de classe un
terminal ne savent pas la fin un quart
des élèves de terminale ne savent pas
nager oui donc qui ne sont pas
nécessairement concernés par ces tout ce
qui est lié à la crise tout offert une
madame portal justement on dit toujours
que le vélo ne s'oublie pas on peut
s'arrêter remonter sur un vélo est-ce
que la natation c'est pareil ce sont des
réflexes où il est quand même conseillé
de régulièrement chaque année à les
refaire peut-être un cours ou de
retourner au contact de l'eau pour
retrouver les automatismes
oui je pense la natation c'est une
banque on est on est pas fait pour
vraiment pour nager donc c'est quelque
chose qui se perd assiette facilement je
pense qu'il faut quand même y retourner
assez régulièrement aussi heureux partir
en vacances avec des jeunes enfants ou
enfin même des adultes c'est je pense
qu'il faut quand même essayer d'aller
régulièrement pour garder le contact
avec l'eau savoir nager savoir se
débrouiller quand on est dans un milieu
on à papier je pense que c'est important
c'est important oui justement vous
l'avez dit on n'a pas ça fait une petite
vingtaine de minutes qu'on parle
d'enfants la noyade peut concerner tout
le monde la natation concerne tout le
monde les adultes aussi
ah oui les amis et aussi parce que des
fois les abus pour l'impression
de pouvoir nager loin de pouvoir nager
longtemps et en fait il se rend pas
compte que des fois il ya et prennent
des risques et oui les adultes aussi
sait on a beaucoup de noyades de
personnes adultes donc
qu'il faut il faut aussi faire attention
enfants 1000 ça ça paraît évident est en
fait les abus de sa part elle fait moins
évident
mais faire attention à ne pas lâcher des
enfants aussi du regard je vous propose
que nous arrêtions sur ces mots c'est la
fin de cette société merci de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau temps
d'échangé d'ici là bien sûr prenez soin
de vous
[Musique]